الولايات المتحده شهدت تطورا اذ قال رئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن بان الكونجرس طلب منه
ان يمررها الاتفاق الذي تم التوصل اليه مع
الجمهوريين لزياده سقف الدين الحكوميه
الذي بلغ واحدا وثلاثين تريليونا واربعه
مئه مليار دولار ووصف بايدن صفقه بانها
توافق لا يحقق لاي طرف مبتغاه كاملا
اتفقت مع رئيس مجلس النواب وتحدثنا في
مساله الموازنه ونحن مستعدون للتوجه الى
الكونجرس الاتفاق في الحقيقه توافق لا
يحقق لاي طرف مبتغاه كاملا فهو يجنب
البلاد اسوا ازمه ويحمي اولوياتها كما
يحمي منظومه التامين الصحي والمعاشات
وانني احط غرفه الكونجرس على تمريره
وكان رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي كيفن
ماكارتي قد قال ان المفاودين الجمهوريين
توصلوا الى اتفاق مبدئي مع البيت الابيض
على حل مشكله سقف الدين الحكومي ان
الاتفاق يشمل تخفيضات تاريخيه في الانفاق
انه لا يشمل اي ضرائب او برامج جديده
واتوقع التصويت على مشروع القانون
الاربعاء
توصلنا الى اتفاق مبدئي يتضمن تخفيضا
تاريخيا في الانفاق الحكومي واصلاحات
الملموسه تخرج الناس من وهبه الفقر وليس
فيه ضرائب مستحدثه ولا مشاريع حكوميه
جديده علي اطلاع اعضاء الكونجرس على
تفاصيل الاتفاق واستكمال تحرير النص
ومراجعتهم مع البيت الابيض وساتحدث لرئيس
بيضا غدا مساء وانشر النص غدا على ان نصوت
عليه يوم الاربعاء
وتوقع مكارتي من الحزبين الجمهوري
والديمقراطيه التصويت بالاغلبيه لصالح
الصفقه التي تم التوصل اليها مع البيت
الابيض حول سقف الدين وتخفيض الانفاق
اخيرا استطعنا خفض الانفاق ونحن اول
كونغرس يصوت لخفض الانفاق منذ سنوات بموجب
الصفقه سنحافظ على التمويل الكامل
للمحاربين القدماء والدفاع لكننا خفضنا
الانفاق غير الدفاعي الى اقل من 22 مستوى
وفي البنود التي قالت الديمقراطيون انها
خط احمر هذا جيد لعموم الامريكيين واعتقد
ان غالبيه الجمهوريين سيصوتون لصالحه
وكذلك كثير من الديمقراطيين كون الرئيس
وافق عليه رغم انهم مستعون للغايه الان
وقد قالوا لي انهم لم يحققوا شيئا في هذا
الاتفاق